last time I promised we would move from
a sine curve - well it's cousin the
cosine okay so if you haven't already
recall the unit circle cuz you need a
new one because we gonna put all kinds
of new things on here and where can we
use the unit circle again to graph the
caused her as you're doing that I just
realized looking at this sound screen I
forgot to show you something which is
what you want to do if you're in if
you're in trouble for instance if you
can't remember what cost forty five is
and you are too lazy to draw those
triangles which should take ten seconds
okay let me show you you can follow
along with your calculator if you like
plus forty five right cos 45 okay you
get this up like we've noticed you get
this decimal rubbish okay and you
shouldn't be surprised you get decimal
rubbish because you've got to swear it
in there right and that's just gonna go
on forever it's never gonna repeat
that's why the decimals then are they
never turn up again okay now my question
is okay well I don't know what that is
right whoa sorry thank you I know what
that is because I've done this number
many many times but you're like I can't
recognize that so here's what you do
what I'm Richard what a rich dude do you
agree but if I square 102 right I'll get
rid of all of the square root science
because square roots and squares are
opposites right so this is going to be 1
squared which is 1 over the square root
of 2 squared which is 2 do you agree
with that okay that's what I should get
right so what I do is I just get my
Catherine I just say now if it's the
answer I'm expecting I get 1/2 okay so
the answer squared is 1/2 so the actual
answer must be 1 or root 2 because
that's the square root okay you can do
this the same with any of it must it
cost 30 for instance
okay how look it up again decimal
rubbish right what I do I'm going to
take the same approach I'm going to
square it before I hit square you
already know what the entries what do
you expect will happen when I Square
what happens to the new Brown should
just be three what happens to the
denominator 2 squared should be 4 right
she looks like three over four to me
okay so that's a bit of a trick that you
can use it's not the greatest I think
it's a vastly superior just to draw
these things they're far more versatile
and they'll help you understand what's
going on or is this is just kind of a
hack to make sure that you've got the
right answer hacks can be useful but
understanding around right so hopefully
I've stopped long enough for you to draw
a circle okay
now let's have a look at this guy and
we're going to read off some values for
cosine okay now side is about the
vertical values right it's the
y-coordinate that means cosine is about
the x-coordinate the horizontal values
okay so I've got my y-axis you x-axis
here I want to start at 0 degrees 0
degrees so drawing a line on angle 0
degrees would place me there okay you
remember I start at the positive x-axis
that's what we broke down on Tuesday so
if I'm there
what is the x-coordinate of this spot
remember it's the unit circle it's going
to be in a be careful when we write
coordinates we go X and then Y it's it's
alphabetical
right so I've gone horizontally one so
the x coordinates 1 the y coordinate 0
but I don't care about the white corner
at the moment the y coordinate gave you
sine are done with that for now I just
want the heirs so I would write here cos
of 0 degrees is equal to the x
coordinate which is 1 that's 1 now what
I want is a whole bunch of values so
that I can put them onto a graph can get
something a bit like this ok so it's
going to next one up you can pick a
whole bunch but I'm just gonna do 45 ok
so you can see there's my 45 degree
angle I'm not gonna market it because
I've got to have a whole bunch angles
the center so be content with the fact
that he looks at out 45 so cos 45 I was
a bit sneaky I already asked you to work
out cost 45 did note right it's one
enroute tooth and that decimal roach
that you got before or five tells you
it's about point seven okay now just
have a look at that there's that about
match you have a look I'm after this
expert one day right juicy looks like
about 0.72 me like I'm past halfway but
I'm not all the way there so this is um
that's right that's about 0.7 all right
let me keep going round the circle if I
go vertical
I went cause you're a cos 45 what's the
next angle it's gonna be close lie to
you right that's that's going straight
up it was nice okay again only
interested in the x-coordinate
what's the x-coordinate that point there
it's up here right there I'm on the
y-axis remember when we talked before
about finding your y-intercept right you
let X equal zero that's that that's the
x-coordinate here right cause of 90
degrees is zero okay do you see that
it's the x-coordinate I'm gonna keep on
going around let's see here we go cause
oh this thing now
I'm going all the way around I just want
a whole bunch of points this is a little
bit like when you have table of values
right except my table values comes to a
circle cause off now I'm going in 45
degree increments around the circle 45
degrees every time so 90 plus 45 will be
135 very good okay now I'm after the
x-coordinate r-type the x-coordinate but
remember just like this sign is all this
symmetry going on right this is a circle
it's symmetrical okay so if this one
over here is 102 then it stands to
reason that this guy on the opposite
side should be minus 1 negative 1 a
routine
negative 1 over root 2 which is about
negative zero point 7 okay last one that
I'm gonna do slowly and then I think the
rest of them we can do fairly quickly
okay over here
I've now we're all the way around and
I'm facing the opposite direction from
where I started right
so zero degrees all the way around to
180 cause 180 that's what I'm asking
here
what's the x-coordinate of this spot on
the axis it's minus one isn't it very
good okay we nailed it so you can see
I'm starting to get a whole bunch of
points let's go all the way around I'm
just going to finish them off he if I
add 45 degrees again I've got 225 the
x-coordinate here should be exactly the
same as the x-coordinate here because
because they're horizontally lined up to
each other okay
so therefore again I'm getting minus 102
okay this guy here is going to be closed
off one right angle surrounding goes
three right angles that's 270 okay and
again it's on the y axis so X is zero
over here if I add another 45 I'm 270
plus 45 is 315 okay it's gonna match
this guy horizontally right and then
just to be neat yeah 45 degrees one more
time
and that brings you back to either 0 or
you could say remember I could say
because I'm adding right 360 right I've
gone full circle but it's exactly the
same as this 360 and zero degrees on a
circle they're the same angle right on a
circle they are okay so now I have
enough pieces to graph this guy right
let's do it in exactly the same way I
went from north to 360 okay I'm gonna do
that on this new set of axes you